one or two players then it puts your
entire team at jeopardy of that one
player doesn't come through Brian
Anderson with a Miss good contest by
jaren Jackson Wednesday at Sacramento
[Applause]
O'Neal in the paint to the left people
follow neighbors right on top of the rim
[Applause]
rolls down the lane and then Jared
Jackson jr. blocks it out of bounds
Emily wood 9 on the shot clock with the
aggressive move his good friend
[Music]
you touch basketball hopping around shot
clock at nine playing down the ladies
who's gonna cram it the
[Applause]
dropped it off come on the other side
[Applause]
[Music]
lockdowns Repco stardate interchange
results an eternal group the deep is a
step up beautiful lob to jaren Jackson
there goes Harris on a drive misfires on
the duck rebound ping-pong around giving
up 14 points off the rolls travelers at
second fewest in the NBA Millsap blocked
by Jaron out of islands that will stay
with Denver but jaren Jackson junior
making an impression crowd here at FedEx
Forum second block the thing which you
don't realize is how long in their feet
so after eight one Denver run Grisi
scores six straight Jackson doing it
again
Anderson away from that rebound and then
on the other end let me keep showing you
my length sponsor fast-break opportunity
and slow
and Jaron stays down folks
what I Jared some for the Jazz
[Music]
would knock away my favours Exum
followed in by favors but Jared Jackson
got there got the initial block get to
the central Mitchell what Sharon Jackson
jr. with the rejection Crowder attacks
with Kontest by Darren again elbow
Rubio I love short
[Music]
and in first off the relay and Utah
extends its lead to eight at
seventy-seven Burks smothered by Jarrod
out of bounds that should be the fifth
block for him tonight but you know what
I love about this first 3:45 of this
game is Buddy hield slips through and
Gasol the rebound the Grizzlies have
gone back to the heel temple closes out
the elites a drives of the double op and
rejected by jaren Jackson jr. taking it
off the hand of Bagley there's another
knock away deletes a skip pass box by
Jared Fox got it back the beef it does
last possessing this block right here is
a big block but it was before can't look
at it almost like twos and threes
anymore it's more like just wing players
and with position as basketball to
switch and it goes on Taj Gibson is
fighting for this hop Henson rebounds
shooting garnishing he does at the small
forward position so I mean like he's
always seen you know more physical guys
but he's playing the three that he is
sports north through with you on a
Sunday afternoon
Tim rolls with the first matinee of the
season in their first matinee game this
week fatigue has it knocked away a
couple nights ago the Grizzlies became
the first team this season to beat
Milwaukee in Norwalk
this kind of season that they've had and
they forced the turnover so far over for
his second rebound deep position by
Jordan block by Jaron Jordan claims his
eighth rebound of the game
Brunson quick crossover move there's Ole
Miss off the glass and DeAndre Jordan
unguarded the amount of aid that he
helped Marshall for the hurricane
victims in his native Puerto Rico
jaren Jackson jr. with the defense
Brunson slipping through the Grizzlies
defense encounters Gasol Jordan Russia
they didn't make the shot it wasn't his
assist trying to deny the wing pass of
the grizzy they never get back to get
movie get back to back no cuts no we
used to run for Paul Lanford Tobias he's
got the earliest punch in if he doesn't
have that you can come back around off
the down spray come on come behind by
Jackson match us defensively and you see
jaren Jackson just following the
seven-foot Gallinari Grizzlies up by one
Terrell just move that's it block Harris
against chance to put a shots blocked
inside by Jackson the play defense this
kid wants to play defense and he's
pretty good at it already can find some
points like Aaron
and that's Quickshot that follow mist as
well to find some points right there and
that's quick shot that follow mist as
well
[Applause]
cantered quick spin Jaron knocked it
free Kanter got it back scored it again
he just wants it more right now partners
have to continue to struggle he's got a
third wheel degree or a [ __ ] saw block
twice by Jeremy Burke
smothered it again
amazing week side deep it Trier
[Applause]
piling to the floor to get a hell ball
Lou da attacks Jeff Ogden again Bob on
the floor Jared's got it
fourth quarter he has been fantastic in
one-on-one situations or in screen and
roll with a guard going downhill he's
been able to get a hand lettered attacks
[Applause]
this always seems to find my crab the
hollis-jefferson and it take it from
behind by jackson-esque a soul and B
with a steel works at what Simmons he
fills a wing as he goes in for the slam
the ball is blocked being a live body
how he relishes those confrontations at
the rim good hands they're slapping it
away from bread x6 is still with 12 to
shoot Jackson another block